Is a nifty little device that was created
specifically for the Singer/ Studio SK 150
and SK 151 bulky machines.
It's a 12 stitch repeat pattern selector to
make quick work of using punch cards
on a manual machine without
a built in punch card mechanism.
If you are lucky enough to find one
of these rare devices, it could also
work for any 9 millimeter bulky machine.
It consists of the pattern selector
device, a needle selector, card snaps,
punch cards,
and it originally came with a unique
number strip for the needle bed that was
marked for sets of 12
repeats of the needles.
As long as you have these pieces, you
can use this without the number strip.
The pattern selector has slots that are
designed to fit over the screw
heads on a Silver machine.
I'm not showing an SK-150 here,
but the screw heads happen to be the same
and I can mount the device on the machine.
The device slips over the screw heads.
There's no need to adjust them.
The original punch cards were fairly long,
long enough to go through the device so
the ends could be snapped together
and the card made into a loop
for continuous knitting.
With the printed side down,
feed one end of the card
into the lower part of the slot.
Once it's moved a few inches through,
loop the card and feed the other end
into the upper slot until it catches.
Then carefully turn the knob,
advancing the end of the card
that is in the upper slot.
Keep turning until you can
join the two ends into a loop.
Line up the ends and join
them with the card snaps.
I'm using a long piece of blank
cardstock as an example.
I don't have the original cards.
Once the loop is formed,
position the card to look like this.
Now, be careful.
I discovered that the Toyota 12 stitch
repeat cards do not fit in this device.
The holes are not positioned
to the same and they will not work.
Be sure you have Studio/
Singer 12 stitch cards.
Be sure the cards overlap correctly so
they don't jam as you cycle
it through the device.
Position the stitch pattern so
the row you want to knit is on top.
Push the reset button so the fingers
of the needle selector are aligned.
Then with the A side of the needle
selector facing you, push the fingers
into the pattern slot to select needles.
Rise the needle pusher and notice how some
of the fingers are
in out of work position.
Using the working fingers as you would any
other needle selector,
pull needles out to D position.
Repeat this across the row
for your stitch pattern.
This is where the special number strip
would come in handy, making it
easier to see groups of 12 needles.
When all the needles have been selected
and the carriage is set for patterning,
knit across the row.
For the next pattern row, push the reset
button again and advance the card.
Repeat selecting the fingers of the needle
selector and selecting the new
needles across the row.
Remember, this device
is completely manual.
You need to reset the needle pusher,
advance the card, and reselect the fingers
of the needle pusher for each row.
Even though this is a manual device,
it can make selecting needles a whole lot
easier and faster with these machines.